let's take you to the House of Commons
in the UK where they're voting on an
amendment right 322 the nose to the left
306
[Applause]
the eyes to the right 322 the nose to
the left 306 so the Allies have it the
eyes have it unlocked good
the question is colleagues that the
motion as amended be agreed to us when
is other live in is a I love the country
now I think the eyes have it the eyes
have it we now come to measure number
two our man the house that I've selected
the manuscript amendment to the name of
Peter Carr will others minister or whip
on duty developed formally not moved
thank you order the Prime Minister
speaker thank you
[Applause]
I'm very grateful to you I'm very
grateful to every to the House of
Commons staff everybody who's put
themselves out everybody who's come to
give up their time in this debate today
it's been a very important debate and
exceptional moment for our country
except a moment for our Parliament alas
the opportunity to have a meaningful
vote has effectively been passed up
because the meaningful vote has been
voided of meaning but I wish the house
to know that I'm not daunted or dismayed
by this particular result became likely
once it was obvious that the amendment
for me my right honourable friend the
member of West Dorset was going to
remain on the order paper I continued in
the very strong belief that the best
thing for the UK and for the whole of
Europe is for us to leave with this new
deal on October to anticipate the
questions that are coming from their
benches of it I will not negotiate a
delay with the EU
and neither does the law compel me to do
so I will tell our friends and
colleagues in the EU exactly what I have
told everyone in the last 88 days that
I've served as Prime Minister but
further than they would be bad for this
country for democracy so next week the
government will introduce the
legislation needed for us to leave the
EU with our new deal on October the
30-person I hope I hope that our
European Union colleagues and friends
will not be attracted as as benches
opposite are or rather I should say the
front bench is by delay I don't think
they'll be attracted by the way and I
hope that then honourable members faced
with a choice of our new deal our new
deal for the UK and the European Union
will change their minds because it was
pretty close today I hope that they will
change I hope that they will change
their minds and support this deal in
overwhelming numbers since I became
Prime Minister I've said we must get on
a jet brexit done on October the 31st so
that this country can move on mr.
speaker that policy that policy remains
unchanged no delays and I will continue
to do all I can to get breaks it done on
October the 31st and I continue to
commend this excellent deal mr. speaker
to the house
[Applause]
or in the water mr. Jeremy Corbyn Thank
You mr. speaker
I welcome today's vote Parliament has
clearly spoken the Prime Minister was
heard yes he was don't argue the toss
with the chair I'm telling you what the
situation is and everybody could detect
the Prime Minister was heard and the
leader of the Opposition will be heard
it is a simple and unarguable as that
Jeremy Corbyn give Mr Speaker I welcome
today's vote it's an emphatic decision
by this house that tea has declined to
back the Prime Minister's deal today
and clearly voted to stop a No Deal
crash out from the European Union the
Prime Minister must now comply with the
law he can no longer use the threat of a
no deal crash out to blackmail members
to support his sellout deal labour is
not prepared to sell out the communities
that we represent we're not prepared to
sell out their future
and we believe that ultimately the
people must have the final say on brexit
which actually only the Labour Party is
offering today is a historic day for
Parliament because it said it will not
be blackmailed by a prime minister who
is apparently prepared once again to
defy a law passed by this Parliament I
invite him to think very carefully about
the remarks he just made about refusing
apparently to apply for the extension
which the EU number-two act requires him
to do thank you mr. speaker I'm most
grateful I think all of us in this house
and aware of the responsibilities that
we have this is a crisis that we are in
and I'm thankful that the house has
voted the way it has done on the
amendment this afternoon that is a clear
expression from this house in you that
we can't commend this excellent deal to
the house this coming of course after we
just saw just to bring you up to speed
with what's going on the House of
Commons there passed the little in
amendment an amendment which effectively
means Parliament with will will withhold
its approval of this deal until the
government first gets ratification
through Parliament on the legislation
now this has kind of changed the
timetable
there will be no brexit vote today let's
go to Andrew Symonds believe he's
standing by still with us
so Andrew if I understood correctly from
what Boris Johnson said there the next
move is the government says it will try
to introduce and get the legislation
passed so that they can have this
meaningful vote before October the 31st
well yes basically this this elect win
amendment turns the whole thing the
other way round basically this was a
meaningful vote which if passed it would
then have led to the legislation passing
the deal into law what's happened with
this amendment is that that meaningful
vote can't take place now it has no
worth that the legislation has to go
through before there is a vote upon it
in Parliament now the question is how
long that will take will it go beyond
the October the 31st deadline as things
stand under the Ben bill which is the
legislation which is meant to prevent a
no deal brexit by 11:00 o'clock local
time tonight the Prime Minister is
supposed to write to Brussels to the
European Union to in fact request an
extension of the deadline that is the
legal situation however what he's told
the House of Commons is that he's not
prepared to negotiate a delay he wants
it to go through October 31st he won't
be distracted by anything he will push
ahead
he will go ahead he thinks that your
opinion doesn't want a delay either and
now the main opposition party responded
the leader responded Jeremy Corbyn
saying we can't have these threats of a
No Deal crash out anymore it's against
the law so rewrite now there is a
question mark
hovering over exactly what is the plan
and will it be that they will push ahead
and try to get it all through before
October the 31st